the corona virus pandemic is expected to
cause a surge in deaths from another
deadly virus HIV there are fears that
there could be an extra half a million
AIDS deaths this year alone the Bleacher
is deeply concerned about the impact of
kovat 19 on the global response to HIV
more than 70 countries say they're at
risk of running out of the
antiretroviral drugs needed for the
daily management of the condition what's
more HIV patients who aren't on ARVs are
thought to have an increased risk from
kovat 19 so how can we protect people
with HIV during the corona virus
pandemic the corona virus outbreak is
endangering the fight against HIV and
that's becoming a growing problem
particularly in African countries where
many lives depend on antiretroviral
drugs the very ones now becoming scarce
because of the pandemic DW is Adrian
Krish reports from South Africa
timbi would have preferred not to come
to the clinic today because of the
corona virus and to avoid questions from
neighbors
timbi is not her real name she prefers
to remain anonymous she is HIV positive
and wants to make sure her one-year-old
daughter does not become infected my
family knows people they judge you it's
wrong it's not right because you don't
know your future that's what happened to
you after all so you don't need to
charge pressing one in five mothers in
Khayelitsha Township is HIV positive a
few years ago two out of every five
children also had the virus but now the
chances of HIV being passed on at birth
are less than five percent South Africa
has made significant progress in the
fight against HIV the government pays
for the medicines and aid agencies like
Doctors Without Borders help with
education programs in normal times a
group of mothers with
I V Meath here once a month but the
corona crisis means the meetings have
been canceled our mothers do gain a lot
from the poop sessions discussing with
peers and living also time to discuss
with the facilitators and things like
that so now that the group sessions are
not are happening anymore it it has
really affected postnatal clubs the
medics now counsel the mothers on a
one-to-one basis HIV is still a serious
problem here the hospital is much
emptier than usual because of covered 19
many patients avoid hospitals and
therefore don't have access to their
medication experts believe that this
could have a strong negative impact on
HIV AIDS but also tuberculosis patients
in the future Tempe knows her medication
significantly increases her own life
expectancy her hope is that in the
future HIV and corona will no longer be
a danger to her daughter earlier I spoke
to dr. Shannon Haider she's the deputy
executive director of un aids the joined
United Nations program on HIV and AIDS
just this week her organization along
with more than 70 other countries warned
that the corona virus pandemic could
lead to a dangerous shortage in
life-saving antiretroviral drugs I asked
dr. Haider why yeah you know we have
sort of these colliding epidemics right
now the HIV and koban and we have to
make sure we respond to both and so
number one on a really practical level
we've started to see some really good
and creative resilient approaches to
making sure services continue but on the
larger scale we are absolutely seeing
the risks for drug treatment shortage
shortages there are barriers in some
cases to raw materials getting into
countries so that production can happen
there are barriers to produce drugs
getting out of countries and into the
countries that need them because of
kovat restrictions and so it's
it's a really important dance to be
monitoring we're shortages might be and
problem solving to make sure they don't
interrupt treatment now what would these
shortages mean for people living with
HIV in mainly developing countries well
you know we've made tremendous progress
in the HIV fight since the beginning and
we just put out new numbers that showed
over 25.4 million people worldwide are
now on HIV treatment but we really
decided to say well how bad could it get
with Kovac what happens for example if
there were a six-month interruption in
all HIV treatment services in
sub-saharan Africa now we don't plan on
that happening but we have to look at
that sort of bad case scenario and doing
some modeling along with w-h-o and the
HIV modeling consortium we found that a
six-month interruption and treatment
services would lead to an additional an
additional 500,000 deaths from AIDS in
this year alone that would double the
number of deaths in sub-saharan Africa
and actually set us back to 2008
response levels so we lose a decade of
progress in just one year Chenin are
people with HIV more likely to suffer
from a severe kovat 19 infection you
know we're learning as we go on that
there is some new data out of South
Africa which is one of the first
countries affected by kovat that also
has a very large HIV epidemic and they
are seeing that there is some additional
severity and people living with HIV who
get Kovan it's not as bad as for people
who have diabetes or existing lung
disease but of course people living with
HIV are aging and have those things too
so it is particularly important that
people living with HIV take precautions
to try to avoid getting infected to
begin with and that we hope to learn
more as you know treatments evolve
vaccines evolve etc now speaking of
precautions there are a check
patients that are avoiding hospitals out
of fear of contracting the coronavirus
how big of a problem is that well it's a
big problem if we're not offering other
solutions so one thing about HIV care is
for a number of years now whu-oh
treatment guidelines have really
promoted this idea of differentiated
service delivery or community-based
delivery so that someone living with HIV
doesn't have to go to the clinic every
month or every three months just for
routine care the idea that someone
living with HIV has their HIV under
control could get three months of their
medications in one visit and then not
have to go back and forth but a lot of
countries before Kovan we're really slow
and implementing those kind of practices
fortunately we have seen a major scale
up in a number of countries of putting
those practices into place multi-month
dispensing community based delivery
community-based care long distance
telephone consultations and those kind
of engagements for questions so in
countries that are moving to put those
alternatives into place we're seeing a
lot less interruption of people services
but in countries that are not moving to
that community love community based
models it's a problem Shanna nadir
deputy executive director of un AIDS
thank you for speaking to DW and now it
is time for your questions about covent
19 and our science correspondent derrick
williams as usual doing his best to
answer them I've heard researchers talk
about trying to mute the immune response
but also saying that a younger stronger
immune system is more successful in
fighting off cough in 19 isn't that a
contradiction
to understand the apparent contradiction
here you have to understand that there
are are different stages of kovat 19
that that patients can go through
the first is usually an initial
infection in the upper respiratory tract
and and that's usually where it stays
with most people that's where having a
strong fast-acting immune system is
really great it's it's able to keep the
disease in check and eventually wipe it
out in some cases it keeps it so
effectively in check that you might not
even notice that you had it but in more
severe forms of the disease if the virus
eventually makes it to the lungs or to
other organs it can kick in a severe
immune response and and when that
happens the immune system can start
attacking not just disease tissue but
but healthy tissue as well that's when
doctors have to step in and and try to
mute the immune response with drugs
because if it spirals out of control it
can kill you but striking a balance
between letting the immune system do its
job and and reining it in if it spins
out of control is pretty tricky can you
tell us more about dexamethasone
dexamethasone is one of the drugs that
doctors now prescribe at that critical
stage of kovat 19 that I just mentioned
when the immune system has gone into
overdrive and starts attacking healthy
tissue in the body a major study in
Britain that's still in peer review
discovered that in critically ill
patients who need respiratory support
the compound lowers mortality by between
a fifth and and a third which is
actually pretty huge dexamethasone is
what's known as a corticosteroid and
it's widely used to treat many different
conditions that cause painful or
dangerous inflammation it's also an
immunosuppressant so it can help calm
down the immune system when it's running
amok but that also makes doctors wary
about about giving patients the drug too
early
when the immune system needs to be
active it's it's not a new drug but one
that's been approved for use for for
well over fifty years now so so it's
cheap it's widely available and perhaps
most importantly on production of it can
be can be ramped up quickly
[Music]